it is an interesting challenge that in
order to motivate people to excel and do
things it's part of human nature that
you need to there needs to be some sort
of incentive so in the market economy
it's very much based on financial
rewards in academia it's very much based
on reputation and so either way there's
competition I do think in academia it's
much more collaborative so I think that
although people can criticize academics
at times for holding back certain
research results and it's not ideal it's
not optimal at the same time I do think
that that there is a real sense of
collaboration and the desire to have
great 22 to create great results
together but I do think that there we do
have to be collaborating more and we are
collaborating more perfect example is
the human genome project so that would
not have come together unless you had
there's many universities and
researchers that came together to work
for the greater good on this project and
ultimately it was clear who the big
contributors were is really a part of
the whole ethic is to try to be able to
track that but there are challenges
because if you're if you're starting to
bring together lots of other people you
want to make sure that you we need to
make sure that we maintain that ethic
for providing acknowledgement to the
people who contribute we have lots of
big challenges ahead of us whether it's
trying to reduce the cost of solar
energy or trying to deliver clean water
so the whole world or you know renewable
energy in general and global warming all
of these things are going to really need
to have large collaborations and I don't
know that we've completely figured that
out yet I also think that it will cause
a bit of it is a prediction that will
cause some pressure and some challenge
for some you from four universities
because right now especially the larger
elite universities they have large
research enterprises that they
can build on and they can they can build
on the reputation by bringing in more
research dollars and to be doing more
exciting research and at the same time
if universities and universities are
collaborating more on programs then the
universities will maybe be asking
themselves well how do we preserve our
brand because brand is important in that
collaboration so there needs to be the
universities as individual universities
need to have a value proposition so that
it's not just a place where faculty sit
and get a paycheck you know it's really
the because faculty can take their
research and they can move to another
place so it will put more pressure on
universities to ensure that they're
doing their jobs and creating that
environment that innovative environment
that enables people to collaborate and
work together and that's really one of
the huge values of universities and a
place like USC for example we've been
around for almost 130 years absolutely
integral to the local community and also
within our own you know we've built up
this faculty over the years and that
enables us to get the absolute best
students to come through and so it's
it's based on a real foundation and we
need to you know as an example we just
need to make sure that we maintain that
and we keep growing and we keep
increasing that or else we're not going
to be relevant